for millions of Palestinians in Gaza the
primary UN agency anra is simply a
Lifeline they depend on it for Health
Care social services and
jobs especially now after months of
Israel's war on the
territory but threats of funding Cuts
could worsen an already dire
humanitarian
situation established in 1949 anor's
mission was to provide relief to
Palestinians lost their homes by the
creation of the state of Israel nearly 6
million Palestinians in Gaza the
occupied West Bank Syria and Jordan rely
on the aid provided by the UN agency
with approximately 30,000 staff under's
reduced funding could impact food Aid
health care and other critical Services
across the Middle East Israel has called
for the suspension of unr's operations
accusing it of supporting what it calls
terrorist
ISM our main goal in the war is to
eliminate the threat not just neutralize
it we know how to eliminate terrorists
but it's harder with an idea onra
represents that idea breeding more
terrorists through various means we
cannot win this war without dismantling
unra the agency has previously faced
similar threats in 2018 US president
Donald Trump with threw more than $300
million in funding raising concerns
about political motives the US decision
was not about un's performance it was
about uh the pressure on the Palestinian
leadership and that's a form of
politicizing of humanitarian funding
that should be absolutely avoided in our
view anra has also been under pressure
because of its role in the debate on the
Palestinian right of return the agency
recognizes all Palestinians displaced
from 1947 and 1948 and their descendants
as
refugees who have demanded to return to
their homes a stance Israel has opposed
Israeli officials argue that dismantling
anra would remove the refugee issue from
discussions anra is an organization that
perpetuates the Palestinian refugee
problem it also perpetuates the right of
return for Palestinian refugees
narrative in order to eliminate the
state of Israel therefore unrea must
become a thing of the
past the UN is investigating 12 UNR
staff who have been accused of
involvement in the October 7 attacks by
Hamas in southern
Israel nine of them have been fired and
one is confirmed dead but the 12 staff
only account for a fraction of anr's
entire 30,000
Workforce the UN agency says it remains
committed to transparency noting no
prior concerns about its staff's conduct
axel zovich
aljer
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer